وكاله رويترز نقلت عن مصادر ان 10 سفن
حربيه صينيه واخرى تايوانيه في حاله تاهب
وسط مضيق تايوان ياتي ذلك مع مواصله الصين
لليوم الثاني على التوالي تدريبات بحريه
في مضيق تايوان تستمر حتى يوم غد الاثنين
تشمل محاكاه للضربات دقيقه مشتركه على
اهداف رئيسيه في الجزيره والمياه التي
تحيط بها وبينما يتجاوز عدد الجنود
الصينيين في الخدمه مليوني جندي يصل عدد
الجيش التايواني نحو
170 الف جندي ويمتلك الجيش الصيني اربعه
الاف
وثمانمئه دبابه واكثر من
3,300 طائره مقابل
650 دبابه واكثر من
690 طائره للجيش
الجيش الصيني يمتلك
ستا وثمانين مدمره
وتسعا وخمسين غواصه
وتسعه الاف وخمسمائه وخمسين قطعه مدفعيه
مقابل 26 مدمره
واربعه واكثر من اربع غواصات واكثر من
2000 قطعه مع مدفعيه للجيش التروي حسب
تقرير التوازن العسكري لعام
2023 الصادر في بريطانيا كل هذه الارقام